[Music]
identity and access management also
known as iem provides three types of
roles that can be granted principles
basic
predefined
and custom
custom roles are a great way to help
enforce the principle of least privilege
by creating roles that have only the
permissions you need
you can define and manage these custom
rules as per your requirements
as a result they need to be maintained
by a user and updated manually with new
permissions as needed
before we begin let's look at some
prerequisites
first off make sure you have the correct
permissions to create and manage custom
roles
custom roles can be created either at
the project level or the organization
level
for the organization level you'll need
the organization role administrator role
for the project level you'll need the
role administrator role
after you create a custom role you can
grant the custom role on the project or
organization that the role was created
in as well as any other resources within
that project or organization
you grant custom roles the same way that
you would grant basic and predefined
roles
you can create and manage custom roles
through the google cloud console
the google cloud cli
or the cloud api
today we'll be creating a custom role at
the project level using the google cloud
console
first make sure you're at the project or
organization in which you'd like to
create the custom role in
then navigate to the roles page
in this demo we'll create a custom role
at the project level
click on create role
now go ahead and give the custom role a
name and a unique id
you can also include a description
launch stages are informational they
help keep track of whether each role is
ready for widespread use in our example
we'll set the stage as general
availability
next select the permissions you'd like
to add to your custom role you can also
filter by a predefined role
this can be useful for when you want to
grant some but not all of the
permissions in a predefined role
some permissions might not be available
to add to a custom role
this might be because they're not
supported or because they're not
available for the level at which you're
creating the role in
confirm that all the desired permissions
have been added to the custom role and
then click create
awesome we've created a new custom role
you can grant principles custom roles
the same way that you would for any
other iem role
just specify a user group or service
account and then select the custom role
now that we've learned how to create
custom roles let's go over how to delete
them go back to the roles page and click
on your custom role
then click delete
be aware once deleted a custom role can
only be undeleted within 7 days
you can create a new role using the same
role id only after the role has been
permanently deleted
this can take up to 44 days after the
initial deletion request
there is a limit on the number of custom
roles that can be created
you can create 300 custom roles at the
organization level and an additional 300
custom roles per project
this is a hard limit and it cannot be
increased
to learn more about creating and
managing custom roles check out this
documentation
thanks for watching
[Music]